[Music]
coming up next madeleine murray o'hare
the founder of the american atheists
address the group's 1990 convention in
saint petersburg florida
ms o'hare initiated the supreme court
case which removed bible reading and
prayer from the nation's public schools
and she founded the american atheists in
nineteen sixty three
as o'hare discusses atheist litigation
and the first amendment in her remarks
[Music]
i'd like to begin uh to
introduce our new our next speaker
it's a little difficult to
introduce whether it's a relation or not
someone who
is so famous not alone
in the united states but throughout the
world
and of course
the name
marilyn murray or madeline murray o'hare
has become i think
uh synonymous in the last 30 years with
the word atheist or atheism itself and
also unfortunately with the religious
community
synonymous with many other things that i
perhaps can't say on television
dr o'hare has been at
the atheist organizing business
and movement
for 27 years now officially since june
of 1963
and her victory in the case of murray
versus colette which removed bible
reading and prayer recitation from the
nation's public schools
that has probably been one of the most
misunderstood decisions ever handed down
by the united states supreme court and
was one of the longest in its history in
terms of actual pages
but what the court said of course was
that religious ceremonies were not
proper in the public schools it did not
say that individual students could not
on their own
uh pray in the public schools and she
will talk i'm sure a little bit about
that
but
after that case
when she was thrown into essentially
professional atheism
having been stripped of her education
essentially that is with an inability to
ever work again in america because of
her notoriety
her
several master's degrees her doctor's
degree didn't really do her any good
because she was thrown into the position
of needing to
essentially start a cause organization
she took the few names of the people who
had supported her through that case
and built a mailing list out of them and
from that mailing list she has
been able to
establish
a living growing
atheist
consortium i think of atheist
corporations
set up
among other goals to survive her and to
go on for what we hope will be many
hundreds of years
she
uh has had many
excellent ideas and foresight as she
established the first american atheist
radio series in the united states which
ran for some years i ran for some 500
weekly programs
she initiated the first american atheist
magazine back in the 1960s she had the
idea of having an american atheist
library in which
books and pamphlets
and anything in dissent to religion from
all over the world would be housed and
stored and that library uh now in the
american atheist general headquarters in
austin texas is filled with over 60 000
some odd atheist books from around the
world going back as far as 300 years old
she
also
was able to reach out early in the game
to international contacts to india to
europe
she has established
a united world atheists
to reach out to the european groups
those of you and the asian groups those
of you who have been at these
conventions before know that we have a
speaker from a different country every
year
the gentleman from france will be
speaking later on today
she has initiated many legal actions uh
the organization which she founded has
initiated over 50 legal actions for
separation of state and church concerns
in its short 27-year history
that amounts to just about two a year
she has established a trust fund for the
future of atheism i know of just about
no other cause organization at all in
the united states that even has a trust
fund at all or has the concept of
putting money away for the future
and
she has
been instrumental in putting together
the idea of an american atheist press
that is to reprint atheist books and to
keep them in print and to keep the
atheist line of thought from dying out
and
to keep them available to people
or available
in the libraries
and more recently the american atheist
news forum on cable television and i
know very few other cause organizations
that are as deeply involved in cable
television as is american atheists
they are usually on in just the city of
their headquarters an american atheists
form can be seen on cable television in
over 100 cities
so she has really been a driving force
for atheism in america
and i think the um
appalachian uh the most hated woman in
america that fact magazine gave her in
the 60s comes from the fact that she has
been an activist of some repute because
of course the religious community is
always going to hate most that thing
which gets out and does the most and
that has been made on murray o'hare
however
to me
she's just mother
and despite her
horns in the head image from the
christians she is a actually a very
loving person
a good mother fine grandmother uh fine
the homemaker pretty good cook great
button sewer honor
and all of those
home type things that people don't
associate with somebody as outspoken as
modern murray o'hare but she does do
those things too
so without further ado dr martin murray
o'hare
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
gee and you don't even know if my speech
is going to be any good or not
thank you also john murray and i do
yield to my granddaughter robin murray
o'hare who is a better cook than i am
i've been giving speeches at american
atheist conventions for the last 20
years oh in chicago new york detroit los
angeles washington dc minneapolis dallas
denver san francisco
just about every place
as the annual convention moves across
the country for the convenience of
atheists living everywhere
i think actually that what we wanted to
do was to give the media in all of those
cities
everywhere an equal opportunity to
distort and misrepresent everything that
i had to say
that is the history of the association
of american atheists encounters with the
media
this year c-span is taping this speech
to be released nationally later
for the first time in the history of the
united states
everyone can listen to what an atheist
actually says
and they do not need to read an
interpretation put onto such a speech by
a paid hireling of commercial media
that is i think what c-span really is
all about
letting the people of the nation hear
and see
giving them the raw material from which
they make their own judgment it's only
reasonable and fair that this is so
americans and i
thank c-span for scheduling this
opportunity that we may express a
minority viewpoint without distortion
without censorship without being put
into an adversary position needing to
fight through
hostile badgering questions even as we
speak
i want to talk to you today and use it
as a theme a current case that is going
on in the united states that is
currently being appealed to the united
states supreme court asking that body
for sergi is
in austin texas where we live
in recent years say 20
members of the american of american
atheists of primary family the murray
o'hare
and i have been called for jury duty
first we receive a summons ordering us
to appear in court with several hundred
other persons so that juries can be
picked to serve at various courts in the
county
if we did not appear
we would be fined
and charged with a criminal activity for
non-appearance for jury duty
the summons asked a number of questions
which we really did not feel when we
received it that were any of the
business of the court but you know what
the hell you go along and you're a good
citizen and you try to do what you can
do in order to be in compliance with the
laws and that's a fundamental principle
of atheism to be in compliance with
american laws
how many children do you have
is the first question asked and then
incredibly what sex are they
will this help you to be a juror and
then immediately after that the next
question up what is your religion
now that's a hot issue
this month you all received census forms
to fill out
did you notice that there was no
question about your religion
this is because there has been a
continuing battle between religion and
the government
and at the federal level
no federal official may ask you what
your religion is
start
starting in the 1860s the united states
bureau of census attempted to gather
information on religion they asked how
many people were religion what churches
they went to and how much money and land
the churches owned
from 1860 until after the second world
war ended the churches fought that until
in 1940 they were able to discontinue
those questions
they will not be counted and the reason
that the federal government found out
that they didn't like it is because they
hid how much property owned how much
cash they had and they boosted by at
least 12 percent
the figures that they gave for
attendance at churches
but here we have in texas
an information form demanding that we
say uh what religious we what religions
we have
well we ignored that blank on the
summons
and we returned it with a
no answer because atheists have no
religion at all
when we came to the courts however
summons in hand
we found out that we we were required to
fill in that blank which demanded our
religion
well all right atheists don't have a
religion what do we do
you put down the word atheist in order
to get into this courtroom and we were
told that by an officer standing at the
door
the blank has to be filled in
and our answer was no it doesn't the
supreme court has said quote neither a
state nor the federal government can
force or influence a person to profess a
belief or a disbelief in any religion
we were literally taken by the ear and
said you put down the word atheist and
then go in and sit down
well we're proud of being atheist you
know we don't mind writing that anywhere
i had planned along the way to have a
tattooed on my forehead
but i'll be damned if i'm going to let
the state of texas or anyone else shove
it down my throat that atheism is a
religion
which brings us to the question what is
an atheist
well the word comes from the latin you
know that theist
means a religious person a god believer
well in words of greek or latin
derivation an a which is used as a
prefix
is what is called a primitive
that is in this instance
it takes away from the word theism and
it means that the person professing this
is without theism
this is simply all that an atheist is
only this and nothing more we are
without theism
don't read into our position what is not
there
atheists have no religion they are
without religion and i'll get back to
more later
but having been forced to put the word
atheist under the category of religion
members of the murray o'hare family were
then seated in the courtroom and that's
when the fun began
the laws of the state of repub of texas
require that a large pool of persons who
have been summonsed into the court take
an oath
about how they will answer certain
questions
posed to them so that they can serve on
a jury
anyone over 65 is immediately out
any person having children under 10
years of age of either sex i presume
it can not serve on a jury if that child
needs attention they care
and also
if anyone is in a secondary or public
school they need not serve on a jury or
if they are in attendance at an
institution of higher low
learning
but the oath is this and i'll read it to
you because the law says you shall
take this oath
not you might you may you will you can
but you shall take this oath
you and each of you do solemnly swear
that you will true answers give to all
questions propounded to you concerning
your qualifications as a juror so help
you god
there we were sitting in a courtroom
with several hundred people
and we were immediately singled out
because we were being asked to take a
god oath which we could not take
so what about us
atheists do not ask god for help
in order to answer questions
as far as we are concerned this is
nonsense
god isn't going to help anyone
answer any question anytime anywhere
simply because there is no god
and that is there he's not going to help
anyone answer a question about whether
or not they can be a juror
or he's not going to help answer any
question when a husband comes home
smelling of booze and perfume
he's going to let him take it on the
chin himself
and this is all primarily because there
is no god
each time the murray o'hare family has
been confronted by this oath they have
refused to mouth it
and what has been the consequences
my son john murray who introduced me was
told to get the hell out of the
courtroom he could not serve as a juror
he was excused from the panel because he
had refused to say so help me god i had
a judge
order the bailiff
to come and grab me by physical force
and take me to his office where i was
locked in
and kept a prisoner until he got rid of
the rest of the applicants for jury
service and then come in and get me and
pull me out in front of his
bench to dress me down
i was verbally abused by this gun judge
because i had refused to take an oath so
help me god
but with rob and muriel here the matter
was even worse
because she was taken to a county jail
charged with contempt of court
strip
searched forced to take a cold shower
deprived of her clothing and slammed
into a jail cell with prostitutes drug
addicts and criminals because she
refused to say so help me god
this is a young woman who was
internationally known as the
editor-in-chief of the american atheist
magazine and whose scholastic record at
the university of texas is probably some
of one of the most outstanding that that
university has ever had she was ordered
to stay in that jail cell
until she submitted to the oath
or another one that the judge might
make up
we had to file a written habeas corpus
to get her out of jail and away from
this kind of brutalization because she
was an atheist
is this a free country for everybody
but atheists
had any of us got past that first oath
had we been picked to serve on a
specific jury in a specific court
elsewhere there's another oath
and again i'll read it to you from the
statutes and you shall take this
you and each of you
do solemnly swear
that in all cases between parties which
shall be to you submitted
you will a true verdict render according
to the law
as it may be given to you in a charge by
the court
and to the evidence submitted to you
under the rulings of this court so help
you god
we're asked
to ask god
to help us
to come to a decision over facts
no atheists need god
to help them look at the evidence in any
court trial
this is simply preposterous
besides there's an old standby
a secular one that could have been used
in any of these courts and that simply
is one
i will under pains and penalty of
perjury true answers give
and two
i will look at the evidence and render a
true verdict on my honor as a fellow
human being
that's all we need
this story was carried on every radio
and television and in all hard media
by hard media i mean newspapers
magazines journals and so on all about
those recalculant atheists who would not
take an oath in god
and just 10 days later
10 days later
george bush
who was running for the presidency of
the united states got into this act
just two one just
this ten days later when he was in
chicago illinois at o'hare airport and
an atheist reporter asked him this
question
what will you do to win the votes of
americans
who are atheists
and george bush answered and this is an
absolute correct quote
i guess i'm pretty weak in the atheist
community faith in god is important to
me
well rob sherman our reporter was set
aback by this so he pushed him a little
bit
he said well surely you recognize the
equal citizenship and patriotism of
americans who are atheists
and bush answered
again verbatim
no
i don't know that atheists should be
considered as citizens
nor should they be considered as
patriots
this
is one nation under god
george bush
well i'll pause there because i want you
to consider that a minute
i don't know what any of you are who
you're associated with but what if
george bush had said no i don't know
that roman catholics should be
considered as citizens
could he have gotten away with that
also had he said no i don't know that
women should be considered as citizens
could he have gotten away with that
even if he had said well they're black
you know he likes hispanics he's got a
grand child
even if they were black if he'd say well
they're black they can't be considered
as citizens
there would have been a national uproar
because he was talking about atheists
there wasn't one single media
except atheist media which would carry
this story it was a total blackout not
one peep
well we got back to bush we're not going
to take it
and since he has been in the white house
he has on two occasions now
had white house attorneys write to us
essentially backing up this original
statement
is this one nation under god
i think it's one nation under the
constitution
listen to this
[Applause]
what kind of nation does george bush
think he is heading
listen to this you all know the words
when in the course of human events
it becomes one necessary it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands which have connected
them to another a decent respect for the
opinion of mankind
requires that they should
declare the causes which impel them to
the separation
do you hear anything in there about god
did they give a damn about god's opinion
did they say when in the god-given
course of our nation
or did they talk about the course of
human events
and then they got to the constitution
and it was even better
there isn't one word about
god in the constitution of the united
states they didn't call on god to
witness that great britain were was
abusing the colonies their concern
first was with the opinion of mankind
not with the opinion of god and then
when they got to the constitution they
said we the people
they didn't call on god at all
we the people in order to form a more
perfect union establish justice ensure
domestic tranquility provide for the
common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and to our
posterity
we do ordain and establish this
constitution of the united states they
weren't praying
they were making an assertion is about
the activity of human beings and what
they could do
god is totally ignored in the
constitution but george w bush doesn't
know that
and the great state of texas
doesn't know it
because they have all come up with the
notion that this is one nation under god
and that's just about as foolish as any
politician do can be
where do atheists fit in a scheme like
this
what about our rights
what about our civil liberties
regardless of what george bush says or
thinks we are citizens of the nation
and many atheists have died in our wars
and many atheists are veterans
i myself am a veteran i served as a
commissioned officer in the women's army
corps in the signal corps in the african
theater of operations and in the
european theater of operations in the
second world war
i served for three years overseas
and there are atheists in foxholes
they are everywhere the nation asks them
to be
well john filed this suit on august 11th
1987 and the federal district court in
austin texas gave a verdict that is so
incredible that i must read several
sentences to you
the judge said
trials are public forums and a citizen
who wishes to see the courts in action
may visit at any time
however there is no constitutional
cognizable right to view the courts from
the vantage point of a jury box
john wasn't in there as a visitor
he had been summonsed to appear
he would have been fined if he didn't
appear and he would have had a record of
that kind of activity
he didn't wander through the court one
day hoping to sit in the jury box
he did not fall into any of the four
categories who were excused you can look
at him he's not 65
he doesn't have a child under 10 who
needs to be supervised he's not a
secondary school student and he was not
actually in an institution of higher
learning
he should have been accepted as a juror
he was excluded from jury service for
one reason and one reason alone
he was a an atheist and he refused to
take a god oath
so he was also forced to profess
that atheism is a religion
now we hear a lot in america and even
the court system has said to us well if
you don't want to take an oath of firm
we can't affirm
we're atheists an affirmation is more
insulting to an atheist than an oath
and the reason for this is that the
affirmation was built into legal
doctrines
only to accommodate the most literal
fundamentalist interpretations of the
bible
let me read something else to you
this is jesus christ giving marching
orders to christians
matthew 5 33 to 36
j.c now
again
ye have heard that it hath been said by
them of old times thou shalt not
forswear thyself but shall perform unto
the lord thine oaths
but i say unto you swear not at all
neither by heaven nor for it is god's
throne
nor by the earth for it is his footstool
neither by jerusalem for it is the city
of the great king and neither shalt this
thou swear by thy head because thou
canst not make one hair white or black
but first
let your communication be yey
yey
nay
nay
for whatsoever is more than these cometh
of evil
and because of this
certain religions refuse to take an oath
and they take an affirmation instead and
we won't touch it with a 10-foot pole
however texas courts
texas judges and now federal judges
all know more about christianity than
did jesus christ
the affirmation was invented to be used
specifically by the quakers the
moravians the dunkers the mennonites
jehovah's witnesses so that they might
quote swear not at all
the case of john murray finally worked
its way up to the fifth federal circuit
court of appeals and it was heard there
on my father's birthday february the
fifth just a couple months ago
now let me tell you a little bit about
federal courts it's very difficult to
get a review from a lower court hearing
only a very few make it up that uh first
rung of the appellate ladder
and of these
hardly any i think only two or three
percent are scheduled for oral arguments
well this jury case was accepted
it was scheduled for oral arguments
the fifth federal circuit court of
appeal knew that it was an important
case and they took it and they scheduled
it
and then the cream got sour
and it got sorry because we were
checking on it and we found that the
court
of the fifth federal circ of court of
appeals opened its hearings with a
special call
hear this hear this this case is now in
session god
save this honorable court
i hope that the court would be impartial
in deciding vanished that day
this was also carried all over the
nation
this is the theater of the absurd
john wrote to them and demanded that
they eschew
the use of this call to god for help
those fifth circuit judges were so
furious that it showed on their face and
in their voices
and although we were scheduled for a
certain uh number of minutes of argument
they got us the hell out of there in
about three or four minutes they didn't
bother
they didn't they hustled the oral
arguments through and they never give
decisions for months after this but with
us we got the decision right away
and this is what the fifth federal
circuit court of appeals said
the occasion to serve on a jury
is undeniably a duty
a privilege and an opportunity for many
citizens to actively and personally
serve their government
but nonetheless it upheld the lower
court decision of exclusion of atheists
from that duty
that privilege and that opportunity
everyone concerned with the case
understood that we lost it at the fifth
federal circuit court of appeals only
because we challenged their opening
john murray is now in the position that
he is appealing to the united states
supreme court
the appeal has to be finished by the
15th day of next month
but my god excuse the expression
the united states supreme court also
opens with a crime
and here it is
god
save our nation and this honorable court
now how can the supreme court in the
nation
be fair to atheists who are asking to
overturn the decision of an appellate
court who called on god
and that appellate court was handling a
decision of a federal lower court who
called on god
who was handling the decision of the
texas court who demanded the jurors to
call on god
how can we get any place with this
the legal system has degenerated into a
poor joke
why do they hate us
why do they hate us
why does george bush think we aren't fit
to be citizens why would he deny us
citizenship in his statements in order
to give the religious cause to attack us
why do the courts from the lowest to the
highest in the land
have an active hatred of atheists and
signal this in their opening
atheists are
axiomatically deprived of all rights and
i'm only talking about this one judicial
right
just now because there are hundreds of
others
several years ago we did a sociological
study of the atheists in our
organization
and we had a sample return of 1500 which
is pretty good we think
1500 of our atheists completed their
questionnaires and what did this show
why do we scare the bejesus out of the
christians
74 are male
96 are caucasians
52
were single
who's afraid of that
why should bush say we can't be citizens
why should we be told we couldn't serve
on a jury
shouldn't we be counted
let's get on
25 percent have one college degree
another 22 percent have more than one
college degree
and another 13
have more than two college degrees
this means that we are a highly educated
group of persons
62 percent
of us own our own houses compare that to
the national statistics
so all of this makes us pariahs
32 percent were under 40.
32 were 40 to 50 and 36 were percent
were 50 or over
65 percent had incomes which put them
into
upper middle class
what professions had they chosen they
are gentlemen farmers antique dealers
environmental planners interior
designers teachers professors nurses
doctors lawyers judges journalists sales
representative commercial investors
engineers of every conceivable kind
builders architects computers
programmers real estate brokers career
armed forces
personnel who aren't even citizens you
see
incidentally a nurse
helped us to put this convention
together right here in st petersburg
but in addition to this atheists were
homemakers students nurses
administrators and executives and
corporations
they are artists psychologists
psychiatrists movie stars madeleine
don't use my name
rock singers politicians
madeleine and i will lose the next
election if you say so
why should george bush consider them not
good enough to be citizens
why can't they serve on our juries why
are they excluded because this is one
nation under god
well let's let's look further
and i think i see a glimmer of all of
the trouble
they engage in the single most dangerous
activity in the nation each and every
one of them
they read
seventy four percent of them read at
least one to six books a month
48 percent subscribe to and read at
least six journals amon
and those are professional journals
news political journals cause materials
and boy is ecology high on everybody's
list they know there's no other world
than this and they're not going to
escape from it they want it cleaned up
what is more important than george bush
should know this 83 percent practice the
franchise they vote in city county state
and national elections
35 vote for what they call an
independent choice 28 percent are
democrats nine percent are republicans
and nine percent libertarians
12 percent would vote socialist if we
had a party like that
but is this any reason
to say we can't serve on a jury
that we can't be considered by the
president to be citizens
the statistics bear out that the
atheists are the nation's finest
citizens bar none
incidentally when religions make a
survey
they pick 300 people and the national
media carries it everywhere
we had a sampling of fifteen hundred
people and we couldn't get a peep nobody
was interested in knowing anything about
atheism
well let's dig a little bit deeper
because we have to find out why do they
hate us
i personally think it's because we're
superior people
but let's go on anyway
every single person watching me or
hearing me even some of you atheists
yes you have feelings of personal
inadequacy
it clings to you in your personal
relationship it's on your job it's with
your family
even when you face yourself all alone
you have feelings of personal inadequacy
this is because every society has a
system of social controls
whereby individual members learn to
adjust to the social behavior of which
the society approves
and this training proceeds from infancy
and the value and the goals that it
instills in you
becomes so internalized in your mind
that you do not question them or even
think about them
in the western cultures the most
powerful institution involved in this
massive psychological and social
conditioning is organized religion
religion is formidable
in that it has the ability to make
disadvantageous and even distasteful
controls seem palatable and even
desirable to any individual
this institution
hallowed by tradition and george bush
weakens the will to act as individuals
since its
doctrines of obedience
doctrines of authority
doctrines of repentance doctrines of
fear of punishment doctrines of
self-abnegation
doctrines of outer direction god is
watching you
rather than individual inner assurance
doctrines of elevation of faith over
reason and the final doctrine of
intolerance
every knee shall bow
brings to you
this feeling of personal inadequacy
if anyone appears who has a mind of his
own and lo here you are
society has means of repression
of subtle discriminations
of economic reprisals and of social
re-education and they hate me and my
family because we would not yield to any
of them
you are inadequate to do anything
yourself
turn to god
pray
find solutions for your problems through
wistful thinking
since you were a child you have been
taught that god is the be-all and the
end-all and essentially that you're no
damn good
and if you don't submit to these ideas
you can't serve on a jury and george
bush doesn't want you as a citizen
some years ago i sued the school board
in baltimore maryland to stop the
reverential reading of the king james
bible and the unison oral recitation of
the lord's prayer
from that protestant bible in the public
schools of the united states
in june 1963 the supreme court of the
united states agreed with me
but before that the attorney who began
the case demanded that i give him a
statement that could be a legal
statement as to what an atheist is and
this was to be included in the case and
therefore to inform the for the court
what we were all about and our motives
for bringing the suit and here's what i
wrote it's still good although it was
written 30 years ago and i think you'll
accept it
your petitioners
that means our family
uh the persons who had brought the suit
your petitioners are atheists
and they define their position as
follows
an atheist loves his fellow man instead
of a god an atheist thinks that heaven
is something for which we should work
now here on earth for all men together
to enjoy
an atheist knows that he can get no help
through prayer but that he must find in
himself
the inner conviction and strength to
meet life to grapple with it to subdue
it to enjoy it
an atheist knows that i know only in a
knowledge of himself and a knowledge of
his fellow man can he find the
understanding that will help to a life
of personal and societal
fulfillment
an atheist then seeks to know himself
and his fellow rather than to know a god
an atheist knows that a hospital should
be built instead of a church
an atheist knows that a deed must be
done
instead of a prayer said
an atheist strives for involvement in
life and not escape into death
he wants disease conquered poverty
vanished war eliminated he wants man to
understand and love man
he wants an ethical way of life
he knows that he cannot rely on god
cannot channel action into prayer
and that there is no hope for any
troubles solutions in a hereafter
he knows that we are our brother's
keeper he knows that we're the keeper of
our own lives
that we are responsible people and that
the job is here
and the time is now
well you need to know also
what atheists are not
we are not realists not secularists not
humanists not agnostics
after all agnostics are simply gutless
atheists
neither are atheist unitarians
we do not hide behind a name because
that name is thought to
handle respectability
the plain bare bone term
is the proudest and the most beautiful
of them all
being an atheist also means at least
this
we do not accept that there is a god
or gods
personal or in nature
manifesting himself herself itself for
themselves in any way
we do not accept the idea of heaven hell
perdition purgatory or any other of the
stages reached by escalator going either
up or down
we do not accept that there is any life
after death
we do not accept miracles we do not
accept the idea of angels spooks goblins
gremlins leprechauns elves or souls
we simply do not accept that anyone at
any time
was ever a prophet of god
who did not exist or which did not exist
we do not accept any so-called holy
books as guides to life and that
includes the bible the torah the veda
the quran the upanishads the waspi the
arrest they invent them constantly
we don't care whether that book was
written
by anyone in history in any age in
history whether that was written by
moses mary baker eddie uh paul joseph
smith muhammad watama buddha or the
fickle finger of fate
[Music]
we do not accept that there is now
or has ever been a holy person
and that includes everyone
from mother teresa
to moses to jesus christ we call him jc
muhammad his daughter fatima the angel
moroni
the pope
any pope all of the popes
any oracles
self-appointed or appointed by other
persons or elected by strange men in
long red dresses
we do not accept that there is any
efficacy in prayer
and we don't care whether they're said
by your legislator
george bush
yourself myself a priest a rabbi a
minister a guru or even your mama
[Music]
atheists see all of this first
as being totally subjective
and going on only in your little heads
nowhere else
and secondly we see it basically as
simply being silly
we don't hate you we think you're quite
odd
but these are all very ancient outmoded
fables and we no longer need to cling to
them in our modern world
the most difficult thing in the world to
do is to live in it
just to get along with other people
to earn a living
to meet our basic needs
and we do not need encumbered
by all of these ideas which bring you a
sense of guilt
a sense of inadequacy of impotence
we need a decent modern sophisticated
workable set of standards by which we
can get along with ourselves and others
and here we are in the atheists and
we've got all of the answers
no god ever gave any man anything
we're on our own
we make it in this world ourselves or we
fail ourselves we solve our problems we
find our happiness we form our
governments based on power derived from
the people
not from god
atheists are materialists also we think
that what you see is what you got
mother nature primarily there are no
supernatural forces nor can they be
the goal of life is to live
whereas your religion tells you that the
goal of your life is to die
so that you can spend eternal life with
god
the atheists say hey
man you blow it here and that's it you
only go around once the beer commercial
is correct
[Music]
make the best of
it is any of this though any reason
anything that i have said to exclude us
from juries to say that we aren't
citizens
well john murray filed this jury oath
lawsuit saying that he considered the
requirement to take a god
the requirement to say that atheism was
a religion
under the first amendment to the
constitution of the united states
but let's look at just a moment at that
constitution because i'm having second
thoughts about that first amendment i
don't think it covers us
it talks about freedom of religion
it says pick one of the above methodist
presbyterian roman catherine lutheran it
doesn't say you can say no to religion
it doesn't say freedom from religion
it says freedom of religion
for the past 30 years american atheist
has been a watchdog organization
challenging church state violations and
fighting for the civil rights of atheism
is it right that an atheist cannot give
testimony in some courts in the land
arkansas
you can't be a witness
should atheists be excluded from any
public office or position of trust
simply because they're an atheist and
there were six states in the united
states said yes until we sued them
should atheists lose custody of their
children
only because they're atheists
should atheists be fired from their
teaching positions when it is found out
that they are atheists should atheists
be forced to handle money daily
which has on it the religious graffiti
under government command quote in god we
trust
should atheists be forced to say a flag
pledge that declares that the united
states is now one nation under god
all of you veterans of the second world
war never said that because that oath
was introduced to the uh pledge of
allegiance in 1954
six years eight years after the war was
over
should atheists be forced to accept the
motto
in god we trust
should atheists be forced
to have the state of florida state model
motto be in god we trust
should we be forced to support religious
schools with tax money
should we be forced to pay higher taxes
on our land because religious
organizations are tax exempt
in texas alone last year i got the
figures that we think are pretty close
to accurate although they may be low
religion in the state of texas owns 81
billion dollars worth of land all of it
taken out of the tax base
it this forces
all other homeowners to pay higher taxes
and it forces apartment dwellers
to pay higher rent
should you be forced to pay increased
sales tax because none of the religious
organizations in your state pay the
sales tax
every state in the union they're excused
sucker
what do you pay six cents seven cents
eight cents
well there you are
should you pay sales tax on gasoline
because religious organizations can pull
up and gas up and they're exempt from
that federal tax did you know that
should you pay taxes on the income you
get from your share of stock at a t and
t your little tan shares are 20 shares
because religion pays not a penny on any
of those earnings
should you be drafted into the army as a
buck private
because ministers go in as commissioned
officers they're not going to share the
same toilets as you
as a matter of fact should you be
drafted at all
when any person who is preparing for the
ministry
is absolutely excluded from any draft
should ministers be free from taxes on
their homes
while you pay taxes on yours
well you know the supreme court has been
giving a bunch of decisions
on state church separation
and some of these are so absurd
that i can hardly believe it but let me
give you two samples
that court the united states supreme
court invented the term benevolent
neutrality
they need grammar lessons
[Music]
and i have heard learned law professors
law colleges judges lawyers
congressional leaders and legislators
argue over the term benevolent
neutrality
now let me tell you neutrality is
neutrality
if it's benevolent it is not neutral
if it is malevolent it is not neutral
there is no such a thing as a one-sided
neutrality that benefits religion but we
go merrily on with this case after case
the other thing that the united states
supreme court has done
is to funnel tax money into church
schools if you wouldn't believe it
under the theory of child benefit
but the thing is i have never heard them
ever use the phrase
child benefit when they're talking about
aid to public schools not once i have
never heard them use the
term child benefit about our hungry
children
i have never heard them use the term
child benefit to do what they can to
assist abused children
incidentally i'm always delighted
when the religious community says
97 percent of america is christian
and we have the highest rate of incest
and abuse of children in the
world the supreme court has fashioned
also a tripartite test
and this is to cover the favor it does
for religious institutions of all kind
i want to take just one
because i want to read what the federal
district court judge said in the jury
case about one of these tests
whether or not
what he did had a secular purpose
quote
the jury oath has the secular purpose of
conferring an atmosphere of formality on
the jury deliberation
and putting persons on notice of the
seriousness of these proceedings
the reference to god
or swearing by god
is incidental
[Music]
the judge lies in his teeth and he knows
it and the fellow appellate judge know
it
even a small child could see
the atmosphere of formality is derived
from in the inclusion of the god of
the seriousness of the proceedings is
evident by calling upon god
have you ever heard anybody call for
prayer that the room didn't all shut up
we should have used that this morning
[Music]
american citizens have been sufficiently
programmed so that they understand they
must roll over and play dead when they
hear the magic word god
the word is venerated in our society and
the judge is a liar
on february 21st american atheists wrote
a letter to every u.s senator and every
u.s congressman
that letter asked basically what are you
as an elected official going to do about
the insults which have been delivered to
12 percent of the population and that's
what the us census says we are
what are you going to do about the
insults that have been delivered
to american atheists by george bush and
by the federal judges not to one of the
senators or representatives had the
courage to reply
however we know why
in prior conversations
with certain of them
john murray was told and so was rob
sherman
we do not dare say one thing about
religion
we would be inundated with hate mail we
dare not even look sideways in an
atheist or we will lose the next
election
this simply says loud and clear
that our constitution is not as good as
a religious vote
there is so much fear in the united
states that these lawmakers are
intimidated
ordinary people are terrified
and also all of you atheists have had a
taste of this terror
i've talked to hundreds of thousands of
atheists i think over the past 30 years
an atheist does not dare tell his wife
what he is thinking
a grandfather does not dare open up his
mouth to his grandchildren
a woman cannot tell her mother
atheists everywhere are coerced to
listen to prayers opening city councils
state legislative bodies even pta
meetings here in florida
if they protest they will be the object
of gross harassment in their communities
they fume in private they're trapped
at a table where grace is said
they despair than they when they hear
what their children relate coming home
from day care cities centers are run by
churches
they are harassed by unwanted chaplains
in hospitals even when i went to the
hospital recently
and that damn chaplain came into my room
and said what can i do for you
i was cordial i was nice i gave him a
short message drop dead
music in shopping centers how many of
you hate the christmas season
[Music]
and then you pay for cable television to
be piped into your home and there's the
last and most gross insult because you
have to see religious programming
because it's all over the the
the entire span
all of this is beyond harassment
it takes on the
attributes of intimidation of repression
of your right to freedom of conscience
it takes away from you your right to
freedom of speech in the private sector
in the government sector every place
[Music]
you all cry over human history i know i
do
as we see what religion has done to
western culture for over two thousand
years
had we followed paganism
had we followed the grecian and the
latin cultures with their emphasis on
knowledge and science
armstrong could have walked on the moon
in the year 300.
we would not have lost 1 000 years to
the dark ages or whole cultures to the
crusades or to the inquisition or that
special blessing from the filth that the
christians promoted the plagues
atheists are here to stay now
we are ready to take over the culture
and to move it ahead for the benefit of
humankind
religion has always been anti-human
anti-woman
anti-life
anti-peace
anti-reason and anti-science
there's no longer any reason for human
hunger anywhere in the world there is no
longer any reason for certain diseases
to linger
everyone in the world beginning today
can have adequate clothing housing
education and health care let's get rid
of war
let's get rid of nuclear buildup
there is no longer any reason for the
patchwork inadequate bungling of the
needs of the human community
viable methods to cope are at hand
they are well known and they can be
implemented implemented today we need
not even wait until tomorrow we are held
back only by irrational thinking and
irrational thinking is rooted in
religion
the world can no longer be
intellectually incapacitated by being
tied to fairy tales invented 50 000
years ago
and then picked up by judeo-christianity
to be put into force
we all need to move into the next
century together on time and with reason
as a guide
and toward that end american atheists
plan to strive
and we ask only that those of you who
have the brain
and the heart to do it join with us as
we try to set the world straight
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]
you don't know how good it is to see all
of those atheist faces out there
[Applause]
[Music]
incidentally i don't know if you noticed
but i couldn't see that damn thing i'm
71 years old and my bifocals need
corrected i guess
i was struggling there foreign
go behind the scenes of the events you
follow on c-span with the c-span update
designed especially for you the update
offers articles about our coverage
profiles of washington insiders and
program highlights every week
so call 1-800-845-9000
for your subscription to the c-span
update and as a gift we'll send you
gavel to gavel a guide to watching the
house and senate isn't it time you got
an update
[Music]
the zip code is
five zero four
[Music]
next on c span two we take you to
sacramento california for a speech by
madeleine o'hare who is the founder of
the american atheists
she gave the keynote address on saturday
at the annual convention of the american
atheists
her address is titled atheists and state
church separation
[Music]
thank you very much jack jones from new
zealand we appreciate your
international contribution to our
convention this year
i want to say that mr jones remarks
uh will be
uh prepared as i've already asked him to
do so in a written form uh which we will
have in a future american atheist
newsletter or journal so that those who
did not attend
this convention can read his remarks
i would like now to proceed with the
introduction of
someone who's very special to american
atheism who probably needs
uh no no introduction
as uh
uh
a part of it i'd like to start out by
saying that
i'm a second generation atheist which is
few and far between in the united states
most of you who are atheists i know had
parents of some religious persuasion or
the other
and i'm proud to have been weird by
not alone an atheist but an atheist
activist
and that
this
activist has been
engaged in this for most of her adult
life
dr mattel and murray o'hare will be 74
this coming april the 13th which is i
believe about tuesday coming up
which is also thomas jefferson's
birthday i
don't know what connection that there is
that uh those two were born on the same
day
but i'm sure that we can make something
she has been heading the american
atheist movement for 30 years
since the case of murray versus curlett
which came down in june of 1963
that removed bible reading and prayer
recitation from the public schools of
the united states
that was the warren court of the time
with chief justice leo warren during the
60s there have been many changes in our
supreme court and i suspect that today
that decision with the court as it's
currently composed could not be repeated
but i don't think that um we need to
be so concerned about that because there
are other cases like roe v wade for
example landmark decision on abortion
that probably could not be repeated
today but at the same time has hung
tough uh
with
the court changes
as our case has
during her
reign
with american atheists
madeleine murray o'hare has accomplished
a number of unique things
she started for example in the 1970 an
american atheist radio series for the
first time
in the world that we know of a series of
radio programs
emphasizing atheism
she had a run of 13 years of this
program once a week on the television
station that was owned by
past president lyndon baines johnson by
the johnson family in austin texas
she initiated the current american
atheist television series which is now
in its 10th year of production
the only series of cable programs
nationwide speaking particularly to
atheist and separation of state and
church concern
she was the first litigant in america to
litigate a separation of state and
church suits suits as an atheist not as
a free thinker not as a minority
religious person uh not as an agnostic
but as an atheist up front saying so and
putting into the paperwork of her suit
that she was suing as an atheist and
because she was an atheist
she saw to it that there was the
founding of the american atheist
librarian archives knowing
that the
written works of those in descent to
religion had to be preserved through
posterity
one of the things that religious folks
have enjoyed doing throughout the
history of the world is to burn books
they're champion book burners and we
wanted to make sure that the writings of
atheists were preserved some place
where
the religious community couldn't act out
their history
she established an american atheists
headquarters a building
uh successive buildings uh knowing that
atheists
needed a kind of a mecca if you will i
hate to refer to a religious voice
but something of this order an atheist
vatican i guess you could say but some
kind of a central place uh where they
knew there was a headquarters for their
activities in the united states
she initiated an american atheist
magazine which was the first one uh ever
to have american atheists on the
masthead and not be freethinker or not
be agnostic or not be humanist or any
other uh word but straight out uh up and
up atheist she fought for tax exemptions
uh for her organizations long hard
fights with the internal revenue service
and got educational exemptions for them
got exemptions from real estate taxes in
texas for uh the building she has been
on more talk shows
radio and television than anyone who
ever popularized the word atheist she
has been on more
of those public appearances and spoken
at more
colleges and universities than any other
atheist
in the history
of this country and probably most of
europe
she
tried to popularize one of the first
definitions of outright atheism in the
world
emphasizing again and that
there is no soul there is no life after
death there is no efficacy in prayer
and she was among the first to challenge
religion directly as insanity and to
come out and to directly uh confront it
rather than to take any of the side
glancing blows that most of the other
organizations had and also she has uh
tried to foster an international
outreach as atheists have reached out to
world atheist meets and reached out to
some of the uh
what have been predominantly atheist
countries of china and the soviet union
and into india europe and australasia
also she is the only lawyer
in the united states that we know of
having a jd in law and earned degree who
has been barred from the practice of law
since her graduation for her entire time
had her education taken away from her
and been barred from the practice of law
because she's an atheist and will not
take a bar oh so help her god
she also
uh is the first uh female leader of a
major atheist organization every other
atheist and free thought group that has
gone before in country
uh in this country or most of the other
major nations of the world uh have had
men and usually old men at that and as
an atheist leader as a woman in the
early days she was not well liked by the
previous atheist leaders who thought
that a woman couldn't handle it and i
think she has admirably proved to them
wrong throughout the years
and i'm proud uh to have
a
a woman at the head uh has been at the
head of the american atheist movement
so with all of that said
i'd like to introduce dr madeleine
murray o'hare to you
and she has some words about atheists
[Applause]
thank you very much
how do you know that what i'm going to
say is going to be good
thank you very much john left out the
most important thing that he could
possibly say
and that is he is john g murray my son
he is also the president of american
atheists i'm 74 and i retired when i was
19 in when i was 65 uh about nine years
ago and since that time of course he has
gracefully permitted me to work at the
american atheist center 12 to 14 hours a
day
for 30 years
or more
i have known atheists
and i'm going to tell you today what you
are
and i hope
that you will understand what i have to
say
an atheist lives
not of his own volition
in a distinct
majoritary environment
and in which
environment he
is in personal isolation
and his intellectual and emotional
suffering
is heightened hourly
throughout every day
he can never forget
that he's an atheist
the surrounding religious world in which
he is is engulfed
stifles him in every outreach
interfering with his personal
relationships
his economics
and his community life
his entire world
is conditioned on a philosophical
foundation which he necessarily
repudiates
at the same time
he is forced to maintain
an exterior
appearance of compliance therewith
the atheist is treated in every social
situation
in accordance with theistic concepts
which have nothing to do with his ideas
of self-worth
intelligence
scientific or human values most
frequently he finds himself
substantially isolated
from any other human or other contact
intellectually he can find no literature
which supports his own arrived at
conclusions in respect to religion he
can speak
to no other man
there is danger of excommunication
excommunication
from the unit human community if he lets
his position be known
most frequently he knows that he must
identify with the culture in which he
finds himself
if he is above the average
culture of his particular friends
family
educational group or community
and his excellence in his job
performance calls attention to him
he must be even more circumspect in his
speech
and behavior so as not to call attention
to his inner ideas
his most immediate and enduring problem
is one of intellectual isolation
his primary compulsion
is to perfectly
perfect
his ability to deceive
to be perceived as one
with his employment peers his family his
social class his community
the more advanced he attains
the more important that his shield of
deceit
be honed to find quality
he is measured by a yardstick not of his
choosing but one which he inwardly
loathes
yet to which he finds he must conform
and with which he must identify
the atheist is forced to pretend
that the unfolding history of the world
particularly of western civilization is
based on the loving tenets of religion
while privately he is deeply convinced
that the history reveals a brutal
suppression of humankind by religion
he abhors
the manifestation and current culture of
what he considers to be antiquated and
inhuman ideas
yet he recognizes
his own impotence
in the face of the culture which has
been swallowed up by those ideas
the atheist is convinced
that the world will not today
be enveloped in the problems it has
if atheism had been the philosophic
foundation
upon which civilization was predicated
yet he has no proof of this
no ability
to even point out the harm
which religion has done
for every in-depth study of history
is manifestly an evaluation of the
benefits derived from the domination of
religion through the ages of man
the attitudes and opinions of the masses
of people
as well as the ruling classes
have been formulated on religious
premises
and so enculturated
as to be beyond inspection
the problems facing the 20th century
atheists are
how to deal with this isolation
while maintaining his own ideas
of his own self-worth
how to challenge
the overwhelming dominance
of religion in all of the cultures of
the world
how to effectively engage in agitation
for reform
of the intellectual climate
and
how to keep from going mad
in the theological balloon
in which he is immersed
the 24 hour a day overweening
consideration of what to do
in the face of attacks
upon the intelligence of the atheist
constitutes a continuing problem for him
he is bombarded with religious
propaganda
the airways radio and television bring a
constant message
the churches in his community are
relentless in their assault
friends relatives fellow employees
acquaintances and business associates
reinforce the idea of the dominant
religion
which he conceives
as
and rightly so
he conceives as insane
newspapers and magazines
are in various degrees saturated with
religious folklore religious
advertisements religious emphasis
seldom or never
does he see a reinforcement of his own
ideas
or
of the harm
that religion has done historically
or
is currently doing
either in nations communities or
individual lives
religion when it appears is exalted
there are either no
only defamatory
or fragmentary negative stories
concerned with atheism or atheists
the atheist is most often confronted
with ideas of self-loathing
if his parents
one or both
are religious
he fully understands
that in rejecting their religion
the parents will understand that he is
rejecting them
their life values their lifestyles
not wanting to risk a rupture in
parental relationships
the atheist again is forced into deceit
he cannot confront his parents with his
ideas
he cannot openly repudiate
that which was of most value to them in
their lives
religion
in doing so he would also force them to
recognize that they had failed as
parents
in so far
as they had not transmitted their most
important life value to their offspring
when disclosure is made
the result is most often devastating
mutual trust is gone forever from that
relationship
a similar situation develops when an
atheist has a child
usually in order to placate a religious
spouse or parents
the children are sent by the atheist to
sunday school and affiliated with a
selected church
after years of indoctrination into the
religion
with what the child presumes
is the asset
of the atheist parent
who has not revealed his true
intellectual stance
the child when he finds out that his
parent is an atheist
is at least dismayed
more often alienated from the parent
for the many years of gross deceit
marriage relationships
are the ultimate trap
since sex
becomes a weapon against the atheist
he dare not reveal his mindset
since it would interfere with a
relationship
particularly it would interfere with his
sex life
dutifully and deceitfully
the atheist will engage in whatever
religious life his spouse
or of homosexual his partner
enunciates
in all of these relationships the
atheist sees inside with discontent most
of which is transformed to an unhealthy
psychological bent
which finally he must direct inward he
has nowhere else to send the message
and this involves then self-criticism
self-castigation
ultimately even with some atheists
self-loathing
the atheist has no one
to whom he can turn
he sees other components of society
where group recognition has brought some
surcease of sorrow
there are those who can physically
identify
because of sex
because of race
the black man is quite obviously not
alone
women can identify one with another
as can the hispanic or children
geographically the indian
masses the blacks fighting apartheid
eskimos american indians
can combine to fight for specific goals
or against specific gross injustices
those who are work affiliated can do
likewise
union workers farm workers factory
workers
and more recently those of specific
sexual orientation the gays have found
clout
in combining
and when it gets to fantasy ideas
there can still be affiliation there
because we have the roman catholics
together
and the muslims
and the protestants and the jews
and they can in unity show their
strength but the lone
cow
atheist
in each one of these groups
is terrified to speak out
fearful of identification since he
cannot endure
the consequences of his actions which
generally is to be repelled by that
group
a lone atheist
isolated in a large city
a rural community
a suburban area
in an institution
a school a prison
or in the armed forces
has no group with which he can overtly
identify
the religion saturated culture permits
none
there are no telling identification
marks for him
so that he may recognize one of his own
among all others in his community or in
his group
the atheist comes to his intellectual
position
unaided
he usually finds first
a religious precept in his life which he
questions
he finds no one with an honest answer
no one who will explain it
he then seeks an answer himself
and i'm talking to every one of you here
and his inquiry may broaden somewhat
but he cannot go very far
since resources are not available
man
being a social animal does not care to
be alienated from the rest of his
species
the atheist desires societal and
familial contexts yet he jeopardizes his
aspiration if he permits his thoughts
to be openly expressed
this is a kind of unique suffering
that only you atheists know
one mind
wandering alone
seeking other compatible minds
but finding none to contact
having no place to rest
social degradation is a specter that
haunts the atheist
discrimination against him is an
assurance not a threat
he must remain silent
out in the human community at all costs
other pressures are upon him in every
direction he reaches
his intellectual segregation
is almost complete by custom and habits
of the era the geography and the culture
in which he lives
the atheist finds that he must develop
communication sets which are safe
he turns to a fine art
his ability to talk about the pseudo
sports of the nation
football basketball baseball
he spends his intellect on trivia
so that he can have relationships
that are shallow
with the religious
artfully evading
constantly that which is closest to his
heart
he knows he is victimized
he knows he is tyrannized
by the culture
his unsupported word
if he should voice it
is immediately and overwhelmingly
disputed in every relationship
he finally over overtly abandons the
fight
because he does not desire that it
should lead to a rupture
in any of the fragile relationships
which he has so painfully and at such
great cost put together
he most frequently
when he feels impelled to the issue
supports a state church separation
argument
but never
never
on the basis of atheism
the arguments of teaching evolution
creationism in the public school
are a prime example
through thousands of pages of legal
documents
and i have read them all
and millions of words in print covering
the vicious fight over this issue
during the last 70 years
in the united states
not once has been has creationism simply
been identified for what it is
a basic voodoo tenant
of judeo-christianity
in fact
the religious community itself
cannot see that such is the case
and often diverse religions
will press forward the absurd contention
that each of the six days of creation
were eons of time
the same anomaly is brought abroad in
the land in respect to abortion
this is simply and only a religious
fight
nowhere is this confronted or recognized
both sides
go to extreme length
to couch the argument pro and con
in anything other
but religious language the atheist is
aghast
to see diverse religious denominations
on both sides
of the fray
it amazes him
that no one on either side recognizes
that abortion is not the issue
he alone sees
that with adequate sex education
adequate birth control information
the problems associated with abortion
would diminish until it would no longer
be significant in the culture
the atheist is forced into a logic warp
to support his preference on anything
but his basic atheism
in the argument to prevent full-scale
religious activities
such as prayer
bible reading hymn singing testimonials
to the lord in the public schools in
america
the atheist focuses his objection
on the first amendment principle of
state church separation
rather than saying
that he is basing it on the absurdity
the futility
and the insanity
of religious teaching
there is no criticism of religion itself
please point to me
any institution even including the aclu
which says religion is no damn good
even in every defining battle in every
case across the nation
and we have them all in the american
atheist library
no one ever says
prayer is nonsense
and that's why it should not be in
schools
and when we grab at the first amendment
this of course leads one to wonder just
exactly why the founding fathers thought
that there was a need for separation of
church and state
if religion
is the panacea for the ills of the
nation
if not for the world the first amendment
should have called for the marriage
of judeo-christianity and government not
their separation
alternately
if advanced now
the first amendment was proposed and
accepted only as a means to keep
government out of religion
was this not based on fear of exposure
of the fraud of religion when faced with
government supervision
with government regulation
to sum up the atheist is faced
with the indisputable fact
that the entire culture of the nation is
predicated on judeo-christianity
since that thought process is in
dominance
it matters little or not at all that
even half of the nation
not even one half
has ever professed to be practicing
judea christians
that the legislative executive and
judicial branches of government
the education and the cultural aspects
of the nation are firmly in the ranks of
religion
is the compelling consideration for the
atheist
another of the isolation factors for
atheists
is that they come from all parts of the
culture
having varied education
part of varied socioeconomic situations
reflect varied ethnic endowments
and endorse varied political convictions
a factory working class stiff
cannot adjust himself
in the rarefied atmosphere of the
psychiatrist
nor can a university professor
intellectually relate to a gravedigger
a heterosexual male
cannot bring himself to enter into
report rapport with a homosexual
each would not be comfortable or
acceptable in the home of the other
the lacto-vegetarian atheist is seen as
a fruitcake
by the healthy beef eating
atheist
the atheist enjoying a glass of wine at
lunch
is held in disgust
by the tea totaler
an associated socio-culture system
must be predicated on atheism
so we do have values that reach across
all these fields
they must be defined
and accepted
be any for any hopes of unity can be
had
atheism per se
as it is seen in the united states today
is not sufficiently a tie that binds
since the full base outreach of atheism
has never been permitted development
artificial and rigid obstacles being
firmly in place
it is inimicable to a militarist
who is an atheist
that another
even though that person is an atheist
would support world peace
however given a chance
to develop the thesis
that there is only life
and to extrapolate on that it is more
that cons than conceivable
that atheists will come someday
to a unison of opinion on this
and say that the only thing that there
can be
in this considered and unanimous opinion
is that the mass destruction of human
lives in wars is a religious
not an atheist idea
however as long as the religious idea
of life after death
as a preponderant one
men will die for god and country
in full anticipation
of that after afterlife
willingly sacrifice the only lives they
know or have
to attain an eternal existence which is
a fantasy
atheists also have a view of history
before them
they have been ruthlessly exterminated
by dominant religions in every culture
in all ages of man
the ability to elude the ultimate
punishment of death
has been thousands of years
in the attaining
in most bitter seasons of strife
necessarily fear is
and has been
an endemic attribute of atheism
yet those brave men and women who did
perish in the fight
are generally unknown to the modern
atheist
who has been
essentially
stripped of your history
you have been stripped
of your heroes
you don't know them at all
they died in vain
the atheist has no social institutions
to which he can point with pride
for anything created by an atheist
and our culture has only moved forward
because atheists have had such creative
ideas
but anything that has been created
by an atheist has been historically
attributed to the dominant
judeo-christian culture
that an atheist may have initiated or
developed a measure of social benefit is
not attributed to his underlying atheist
value system which quite frequently he
does not let be known
but rather
it is attributed
to his philanthropic attitude which was
developed by him
by his reliance upon the judeo-christian
ethic of his times
he cannot win the game
had he not been nurtured and natured on
judeo-christianity
this is seriously proposed that he would
not have attained the level of human
social consciousness necessary to
recognize a social problem or implement
a solution if he had really been an
atheist
it does not help that the atheist in
question
most probably escaped from his
loneliness
in the dominant religion
in order to be accepted he must have
been most circumspect permitting his
motives to be viewed
as being based entirely on
judeo-christian considerations
what bitter frustration
and intercontradictions
often this has caused
the atheist pays with ostracism if he
admits his atheism
he pays with shame
for his lack of courage if he does not
he pays with isolation
or deprivation of cultural conduct
and contacts or he pays with his own
knowledge of his own deceit in order to
retain
the association of persons with whom he
is basically in disagreement
atheists generally come to know one
another by chance
often their association one with another
are fleetings since their bases in the
culture are not homogeneous they are as
i have been indicated culturally
separated by more than their atheism
since they have never been free to
develop their own social value system
the problem then becomes a one
of how to force recognition of the worth
of the atheist how to attain the advance
of acceptance for him
in the human community
how to re to guard
against regression
of his position
or the simple overwhelming
overshadowing of atheists by the
judeo-christian
community
given the current
and future power
of the electronic industry
actually the atheist realizes
that there must not only be an
acceptance of his right to hold his
opinion
but that ultimately his is the job to
turn the culture from religion
to eliminate those irrational ideas
which has have held the human race
enthralled
which have held
the human race in intellectual slavery
unfortunately the ability to affect the
culture still is predicated on the use
of wealth
and political power
political power is simply
the manipulative use of wealth
and also
we need an outreaching education to the
mass of humankind
the atheist few
scattered
intellectually cowed
driven by fears of ostracism
have never had
and do not now have
these weapons at hand
even unto death
the atheists atheism takes a price
if upon his death the atheist desires
that his inner life be recognized
those who survive him in his immediate
circle
be they family friends or members of the
social order frequently thwart his
desires
if an open atheist tales
of his death bed renunciation of atheism
are immediately circulated
if a hidden atheist religious services
are heaped upon his body
and in our culture and in our
organization
the wives send us pictures of open
caskets with the atheists
a bible in hand
often the solution of the atheist has
been seek to do
has been to seek
to duplicate the outreach of religion
we have this constantly
to propose that there be atheist alm
houses atheist orphan homes atheist soup
kitchens atheist foster homes to prove
to the populace at large that atheists
care
this in fact proves nothing
but that there are philanthropic
feelings in all persons
and that the religious institutions have
not been able to stifle them
judeo christianity has
with the help of the ruling class and
government
simply usurped such functions
with a false display of humanitarian
concern
to improve their own image
for what is inherent in all humankind
not alone in the religious
the atheist often has another private
and personal attempted solution
he rationalizes his own individual
position as exceptional
in the quiet of his mind he feels his
outward demeanor
his acceptance of the religion around
him
is a grip
in which he is caught
and must endure
while all the while
intellectually inside
he sets himself apart
but he cannot carry the burden
of that position alone in isolation
he is assaulted
on all sides by the negation of the idea
and as i said sometime finally succumbs
to self-loathing
then he starts to hammer on the door of
religion
he wants to be accepted as equal to the
religious
he advocates associating with religious
leaders for mutual benefit in the
community
he longs to stand side by side on equal
status with the minister the priest and
the rabbi
do you know how much trouble i get in i
am called for a television show
and when i get there they say well now
you know we're going to have a priest
administer a rabbi and you
i said no you're not
if you had a brain surgeon in here
would you call in a witch doctor to sit
down with him
and i walk off the set
john alienated
50 or 60 atheists in one evening
he went on a television program
a priest come in with that black word
black
call it with a
backward caller in the black dress they
wear black to mourn
for their dead brains
this priest comes up to glad handgarth
holds out his hand
and garth says to them
you are an enemy of humankind
i will not touch you i cannot recognize
you i will not shake hands with you
60 atheist members walk out
because we haven't been kind love filled
consider it an understanding
so
if nothing else the atheist wants to
challenge the religious leader then in
debate
but unfortunately this is always on the
grounds of religion
the bible
the debate he feels must between equals
it does not dawn on the atheist that the
minister the rabbi the priest
and the guru are intellectually inferior
to him
as he seeks understanding and
recognition
the judgment of the atheist is sometimes
impaired
hence
it is almost impossible
to obtain a consensus of atheists
they are basically
ignorant of the tenets of their
predicated principles they are ignorant
of the ramifications of them
they are ignorant of the intent
and purpose
quite frequently of an outreaching
organization
there is a widespread ignorance in the
atheist community of their overall
plight
of the undoubted existence of sheer
malevolence
which is and has been directed against
them
let me go back
briefly most atheists have come to
atheism
by being assaulted
with the irrationality of religious
precepts and usually they stumble upon
something
and usually it's in the bible
with any further study they find the
bible
is shocking
barbaric
anti-intellectual and if they grasp it
completely idiotic
yet they have no one to question
when they challenge their minister this
is a closed avenue
the ministerial report is an admonition
to accept through faith
that which cannot be accepted through
reason
so the atheist seeks elsewhere but there
are no books
in libraries no atheist books there are
no atheist books in schools
none in colleges not in universities
there are none for sale in the comp
contemporary scene
book stores
how many has ever have you have ever
walked into walden's
and said give me an atheist book and got
it
bookstores do not stalk atheist books
everything is covert
the culture in which the atheist is
wrapped
is a result of inherited customs
of irrational actions of men who control
the thoughts the idea and the deeds of
the many
the majority against
the atheist is powerful steeped in tens
of thousands of years
of controlled history and controlled
learning
the atheist has often attempted counter
moves
trivial as they have been
atheists have tried to organize
to collect resources to teach the few
others they can uncover and reach but
the road is long
the job is difficult it is ill financed
the reprisals are psychological at least
economic
most often physical
there are 25 million atheists
in the united states
and of this
most of them have lapsed into apathy
vis-a-vis religion
they see no evil hear no evil speak no
evil
they escape into a mental limbo
which has been a major curse of the
human race
apathy
they live as if they see no evil in
religion
hear no evil about religion and they
speak no evil of religion
they seek neither recognition of atheism
or justice for atheists
they get along
now and again an emboldened atheist
leader rises who will not plead either
for justice or recognition
he will demand it as a right and again
this place is the ordinary atheist on
the defensive
he lacks training intellectual and
educational habits
because he is a part of the christian
culture
extreme plans fade with him to a more
moderate council
boy what you think about in your bedroom
at night
and what you do in the job in the
morning
there are efforts to sustain a group
which
then
usually is small
for example
in los angeles
i'm speaking in california
a city of 3 million
a group of 30 atheists will meet and
congratulate themselves that they have
gained some ground
simply because they know one another
this is patently absurd
if the atheists cease
to agitate
if they cease to resist oppression
it will grow
this religious culture on us to be
accepted as normal and inevitable
and what is needed is concentration
concentrated planning by the atheists
the cost of any assault upon the
majoritarian religious culture must fall
first and primarily
on the atheist
it's ridiculous to think that any part
of the majoritarian culture will finance
a program
which it fears and rejects
we're never going to get any money from
ibm
we're never going to get a grant
from any part of the united states
government
atheism was deliberately set up by the
government
as an enemy of our nation
for many decades after world war ii
because our nation was confronting the
evil empire of atheistic communism
with the christian
capitalist
front
indeed the implosion of the ussr
is given as a result
and how many of you have read this
as a result of the evils of atheism this
is why the ussr fell
and it is easy for the dominant
the dominant judeo-christian culture to
dismiss atheism in the united states
with both a shrug and another life
it is however possible
that this small part of the culture
which is organized
not the 25 million who remain
unorganized but it is possible that the
small part of this atheist culture which
is organized could become important
and wield power
so that its influence could be felt
religion dominates our entire culture
the government education intellectual
life politics the judiciary system the
arts architecture city planning well
this is a small job
we are now in a season of change
and as we seize the window of
opportunity
for the last time presenting itself
we either do it or we must lose forever
as a religion
tightens its grip
on every country in the world
religions will persist for generations
and therefore careful and intelligent
action against it must be planned
the plan of action must be taken
to be
to take over the basis of the culture of
the future
nothing else will suffice
one method of attaining this is
continued agitation protest propaganda
toward that end
we must on the other hand
have an unmolested and unthreatened
chance
for free and favorable development
and this is not available
in the united states
the picture in our nation is grim
we cannot let our future remain largely
in the hands of religious majority
or we cannot
permitted to remain
to be changed by chance
accident or situation
we need careful thoughtful and
intelligent planning
we must make it possible for atheists to
await ultimate intellectual emancipation
for the population and we must do this
with reasoned patients
with equitable temper with every
possible effort to raise the social
status and increase the efficacy of the
group
this is not an effort toward cooperation
with religion or inco operation
into the religious group but rather for
its complete overthrow and elimination
from our culture
we need atheist teachers
atheist courses in elementary high
school colleges and universities we need
large social contact with atheists
we cannot come about
into this intellectual freedom until we
have developed our own cadre
for those of you who have been in the
army
for training and education of atheists
there is needed
quicker acculturation
right now
if atheist courses were introduced into
public schools its teachers would not
receive decent treatment nor would the
students receive a real education in
atheism
and this is not the fault of religion
because there are no courses
in atheism available
no course outlines
no regimes of atheist education no
lesson plans no textbooks no reference
resources
all of this must be organized
ethical teacher teaching
character building
organized charity
neighbor holiness
are all concentrated in the churches
and yet to quote one of the
black men of our nation who
has been a hero of mine
the churches are seats of senseless
dogma
and meaningless ceremonies
together with a multitude of activities
which have no social significance
and lead to no social betterment
all of his work is ahead of the atheist
he has not as yet been given a chance to
fight he must himself make that chance
seize it and do what is the necessary
no advance
will ever be given to him
knowing whence he came knowing how bad
it is
no
matter that he knows where he is now
he must make the decision
for the present
and in making that decision for the
present he makes it for the future
this is what american atheists have been
about for the last 30 years
the story is told of atlas that he said
give me a place to stand and i can lift
the
world the atheist must make his own
place to stand
and he then will still have the chore of
lifting the world
and so it is that given the recognition
of his problems
and i've enumerated them here and you
know what that i what i have been saying
applies to all of you each and every one
the atheist must abandon his defensive
positions
take up the cudgels and go forward
rather than
into the retreat of apathy
he must let the blows fall where they
may
my father fought for the rights of the
working man incidentally although
he was a general contractor
a civil engineer
and as long as he lived he fought for
the working man he would only hire union
men in his company
i was reared in a home that loved and
respected labor leaders and one of the
heroes i knew about
from the time i was we was joe hill
that is joe hoglund a swede who became
an american labor leader and a
songwriter
he was known first as joseph hillstrom
and then simply he became known as joe
hill
he was born in 1879 and he migrated to
the united states in 1901
and he became active in the industrial
workers of the world
the union movement
uh and
in 1910
he helped the iww organize strikes
and for that he was executed by the
state on a trumped-up charge of murder
in 1915
at age 31.
he was a hero of the radical labor
movement
in the united states a hero of my father
and a hero of mine
and really
i have nothing to say about him
but what i want to talk about is ralph
chapman
on the occasion of joe hill's death
ralph chapman wrote a poem about him
and the title of that poem is mourn not
the dead
i'm 74 years old now i'm diabetic
and i'm in really rotten health
and i hang on to life where there is
nothing else that i can do
but hang on and fight
and i'll die too and this this poem
expresses my feeling about my own death
and i admonish you that when i do die
you should say
mourn not the dead
and
this
is important
essentially even though you do not know
your own history
you do not know your own heroes
they have all been butchered by
judeo-christianity
i give the advice of the last stanza of
this three stanza poem
of ralph chapman to all atheists
everywhere now
i've had this printed into a book plate
and it is on every book that i own
mourn not the dead
but rather mourn
the apathetic throng
the cow
and the meek
who see the world's great anguish
and it's wrong and dare not speak
this is what is wrong with the atheist
movement
not alone in the united states but in
the world
atheists feel that they dare not speak
and that is wrong knowing what we are
knowing how it is
knowing that the worst may come
atheists must speak out
and i invite them all to join american
atheists in that fight
all anybody has to do is call
information
in austin texas
and say i want the telephone number of
madeleine murray o'hare
and let's get into the fray
we must dare to speak
[Applause]
madeline murray o'hare gave this keynote
address on saturday at the annual
convention of the american atheists
if you have any comments write to the
organization the address is post office
box 140
195 in austin texas and the zip code is
78714
coming up in a few moments here on
c-span we're going to show you a recent
debate held by the candidates for mayor
of los angeles
next on public lives brian lebeau
discusses the atheist madeleine murray
o'hare it's a biography of the woman who
founded the american atheists this talk
runs about an hour
welcome to the c-span crew nice to have
you with us and welcome to all of you
pleased you could join us and that you
have some interest in this really
fascinating woman
to whom i hope i can do some justice
tonight what a wonderful setting to be
at unity temple
devoted to all faiths
multi-denominational
to be talking about a woman who offended
all faiths
so there's some irony in that but it's a
wonderful setting
as well
in the
rather short time i have to cover this
woman's rather fascinating life i
thought i would focus in essentially on
five questions the first is really about
me that will be brief and the other for
perhaps a little longer first of all how
did i come to write this book about
madeleine marie o'hare
secondly who was she because most people
know the name but they get a little
confused as to what exactly she did
why did she do
what she did which became very important
to me in my research
what was life like for madeline mario
here after her most shining moment on in
1963
and then how did she die a faith that is
still
somewhat unclear in the minds of of many
people
so let's begin with that and start first
of all by answering how i came to write
this book
i'm a historian of american culture and
my various books have dealt with
art and literature
public memory
and religion which i've written quite a
bit my interest in religion is really
less about belief and doctrine and
church teachings than it really is on
religion as a phenomenon in american
society
i always found it fascinating to study a
society that takes such great pride on
its provisions in the first amendment
for the separation of church and state
and that rejects theocracy of all forms
at home and abroad but by most measures
percentages of people who believe in god
who belong to particular churches who
attend church regularly who believe that
god plays a major role in their lives is
one of the most religious nations
on earth indeed i think we could make
the case perhaps on another night
that really belief in god and in the
special relationship between god and the
united states
really a civil religion has been part of
the american psyche or identity
from its very founding
uh and i think you can see it
reflections of it in presidential
rhetoric and phrases such as one nation
under god
and our pledge of allegiance our
national motto and god we trust and so
much more
what attracted me to madeline murray
o'hare in particular was my interest in
the place of atheism non-belief unbelief
in such a nation in particular the role
of atheism in the united states at a
time period where religion was actually
at its peak when fervor was most intense
during the early cold war the period of
late 40s 1950s and early 1960s when uh
not only were more americans engaged and
espoused and in believing in organized
religion than any other period but also
when our mortal enemy abroad at home was
atheistic communism and we defined
ourselves largely in terms as being
quite the opposite free and religious so
that led me to study madeline murray
o'hare it's kind of the example the
epitome of atheism in this particular
time period
so who is madeline murray o'hare on
december 8th 1960 madeleine murray not
yet o'hare
filed suit in the superior court of
baltimore maryland asking the court to
rule required bible reading and
recitation of the lord's prayer
in the city's public schools
unconstitutional she claimed that her
son williams first amendment rights were
being violated that he was being
discriminated against because he when he
refused uh to participate in the
school's morning religious exercise he
was alienated or isolated from his
fellow students
defeated in the lower courts madeleine
appeared what became murray vikralit to
the united states supreme court where it
was joined with a similar case out of
pennsylvania shemp versus school
district of abington township
and on june 17 1963 the court found in
favor of the murrays and the shems by a
margin of eight to one declared that the
maryland and pennsylvania laws violated
the establishment clause of the first
amendment effectively removing organized
teacher-led prayer from the public
schools
although this didn't occur in a vacuum
indeed there were several cases that led
up to this one the year before ingol
vitale in 1962
nevertheless much of the nation was
really quite stunned and angry but
whereas the shems who had taken a low
profile throughout the case shunned the
limelight
murray seized it she took credit for
having single-handedly banned bible
reading and prayer from the nation's
public schools she overstated the case
but americans searching for someone to
blame were only too willing to accept
her claim
when she chose to become the leading
proponent of atheism or opponent of
religion whichever you prefer she became
not only the most visible of american
atheists but she also became as the
press quickly branded her the most hated
woman in america
the details of madeline murray's life
who upon her second marriage in 1968
became madeline murray o'hare are
fascinating but equally interesting i
think is how americans responded to her
similarly her ideas on religion are
interesting but no more so than how
those ideas related to american culture
from the cold war to the end of the
century
as her son william who later broke with
her
over her atheist activities wrote i
think he was at least partly correct in
reality my mother did not create the
time the time created her
madeline murray o'hare struggled against
the cultural and political consensus on
many subjects especially religion
not being content to personally and
quietly reject the idea of belief in god
she launched a crusade against it
now important point here i think we need
to make if you have any
memory of madeleine mario here is in
contrast to how the press and i think
her enemies portrayed her madeline
murray o'hare was really quite
intelligent and well educated both
formally and informally especially for
the time in which she grew up
yes she was crude
she was vulgar
her use of foul language shocked people
but her message was always accessible to
even those with just a minimal education
and she made very effective use of the
media
by her personal behavior
somewhat exaggerated by the enemies her
enemies and the press she personified
really what people expected of atheists
she fulfilled americans expectations of
what would happen if someone were to
lose his or her faith in god
in her hands atheism was no longer
exclusively a matter of scholarly debate
or hushed acceptance among fringe groups
o'hare placed it near the top of
america's public agenda where her
enemies maintained it threatened to
subvert the base and pervert all that
was holy or good in american life
now again to understand this we have to
put it in the context in which she was
popular coming of the cold war witnessed
the campaign against international
communism the fact that the soviet union
was not just a military foe but a nation
committed to communism and atheism posed
a unique challenge to the united states
american anti-communists insisted that
communism was not only opposed to
religion but also the natural enemy of
religion and those countries founded on
belief in god
thus communism popularly branded
atheistic communism became anti-american
as well and the united states became a
bulwark against it at home and abroad
this added to the urgency of the battle
against atheism as one observer pointed
out whenever their opponents began
railing against those atheists the
latter ceased to be individuals who
mattered to god instead they became
quote a monolithic mass of faceless
enemies and in a war there's no
fraternizing with the other side
the hunt for atheistic communists was on
and to underscore it in 1954 congress
added the phrase under god to the pledge
of allegiance
signing the law on flag day june 14 1954
president dwight eisenhower praised the
edition for reaffirming the
transcendence of religious faith in
american heritage and future
on july 11 1955 he signed a federal law
which required in god we trust on the
nation's currency
on july 30th 1956 he made it the
national motto
on july 4th 1953 eisenhower and vice
president nixon launched the march of
freedom a movement intended to affirm
america's spiritual heritage and the
divine basis of its freedom
in 1955 eisenhower told the nation
recognition of the supreme being is the
first the most basic expression
of americanism without god there could
be no american form of government nor
any american way of life and this
continued through the 50s and into the
early 60s
o'hare
protested that she wasn't a communist at
one point in her life she actually did
grow fairly close to the movement
subscribed to elements and communist
ideology but ultimately she renounced
her ties to communism
but even if she had no involvement with
the movement she would have she could
not have escaped the label anyway when
she stepped into the national limelight
as an atheist most americans could not
help but see her as a communist as well
and therefore a national threat
similarly atheism and immorality were
linked cold war americans believed that
be a more to be a moral person you had
to be religious
probably christian
therefore americans associated o'hare
with what they saw as the growing
immorality of post-war america and her
private life confirmed that association
in the minds of many this person's
denial of god has opened the door to a
selfish vulgar and often immoral
lifestyle wrote one observer words like
liar cheater hypocrite publicity seeker
only scratched the surface in describing
this individual's depth of personal
corruption
for many americans o'hare was proof that
the arch enemy was real
and in their midst
as i'll show in a moment madeline mayor
madeleine murray o'hare
was no angel she violated some of the
nation's most sacred codes of behavior
but she didn't have to put her
transgressions on display for the nation
to see
others shared her beliefs and engaged in
the same socially unacceptable behavior
but they chose to do so quietly
out of the limelight
o'hare seized the moment claimed full
responsibility and challenged the
believing public to contend with her
i'm more than an atheist i'm in fact the
atheist wrote madeline murray oh here in
1965 playboy magazine asked madeline if
her crusade to separate church and state
was her raison d'etre she replied that
it was only one expression of her raison
d'etre she was an atheist but she was
also an anarchist a feminist an
integrationist internationalist all the
otherists that people seem to find so
horrible today i embraced them all
the public response to o'hare may best
be described as a firestorm and as even
one of her critics was forced to admit
he had never seen anyone with such a
breathtaking willingness to endure
public hatred
but why did she do this why did she so
willingly assume such a persona as one
critic puzzled she thoroughly
personified the christian stereotype of
an atheist rude impertinent blasphemous
a destroyer not only of beliefs but also
of esteemed values
she popped off like a chain of fireworks
in a sanctuary merrily detonating
everything we hold dear it was
impossible not to admire her nerve while
at the same time wondering at her
apparent in compulsion
to be loathed
was she simply committed to changing the
world
to making it by her way of thinking a
better more humane place
not entirely there were some personal
reasons for her behavior as well and
that takes us back really to her early
life and i would say that one thing that
really helped me through this is i was
the first other than a few newspaper
people actually have access to her
diaries which really did open up a whole
new area of this exploration
madeleine was born madeleine evelyn mays
on april 13th 1919 in pittsburgh
pennsylvania madeleine recalled i don't
believe there could have been a happier
or more secure childhood than mine
she described her mother as beautiful
her father as a knight in shining armor
and her life is growing up amidst
affluence typically the account was
exaggerated but madeline did live a
comfortable life as a child at least
until the great depression when the
stock market crash destroyed her
father's business uh and then for the
next uh several years the family moved
from place to place while john mays
sought work and money to support his
wife and children
madeleine often referred to those years
in their influence on her later life if
once prosperous and carefree that was no
longer the case moreover by her telling
the hardship she suffered bored the
seeds of her later rejection of god her
father was presbyterian her mother was
lutheran her parents baptized madeleine
the presbyterian church at the age of
four and she attended church on and
sunday school
somewhat irregularly
then at the age of 12 or 13 as madeleine
tells it while in the sixth grade and
living in akron ohio madeleine read the
bible
she read it cover to cover in one
weekend she later reported and quote
realized it was a perfectly bizarre book
she was completely appalled totally
turned off and filled with repugnance by
what she discovered
i came away stunned with the hatred the
brutality the sadomasochism the cruelty
the killing the ugliness
at about the same time while attending
church she began to take note of the
ministers accusing his flock of being
full of sin
though he never explained why instead
they passed a collection plate and i got
in my mind that this had to do with the
purification of the soul that we were
being invited to by expiation for our
sins so i gave it all up it was too
nonsensical
the maze were not enthusiastic
churchgoers as i mentioned earlier
nevertheless when madeleine explained
her conclusions concerning the bible to
her parents and read them the offending
passages her mother simply drew herself
up and responded that's not in my bible
madeleine was not to be dissuaded
however i never accepted the bible after
that day i refused to go to sunday
school anymore and i refused to go to
church
the maize family may have been poor as a
result of the depression but in 1936
madeleine was able to spend one year at
the university of toledo
in 1938-39
she enrolled at the university of
pittsburgh when the family returned to
that city but she did not graduate
instead on october 9 1941 at age 22 she
eloped with john henry roths a steel
worker a local guy who madeline had met
in high school
two months later the roth's marriage was
disrupted by american involvement in
world war ii
both enlisted but received separate
assignments
he became a marine and was sent to the
pacific she enlisted in the women's
auxiliary army corps and was
commissioned as a second lieutenant she
served on the cryptographic staff in the
supreme allied headquarters in north
africa france and italy while stationed
in italy lieutenant madeleine roths met
and conceived the child with william
murray jr an officer in the u.s eighth
army corps
according to their sons william when
madeleine returned her son william when
madeleine returned home from the war her
parents were living in a shack with no
electricity or running water her father
had spent on booze all the money she had
sent for savings the family was
destitute she was pregnant
when roth returned he offered to stay
with his wife and raise the child as his
own but o'hare declined and proceeded to
sue for divorce according to madeleine
murray refute murray the father of the
child refused to leave his wife because
he was a catholic and opposed to divorce
but he actually denied he was the father
forcing madeleine to establish his
paternity in court in order to receive
child support
although william murray's refusal to
divorce his wife cannot be ascribed then
solely to his being a catholic
his son concluded that it provoked and
uh his mother's antagonism toward roman
catholicism which was always her prime
enemy
and god the latter symbolized by one of
the most dramatic episodes in
madeleine's life
one night in early 1946 during a violent
electrical storm madeleine still
pregnant and in despair announced that
she was going out in the storm to
challenge god to strike her and her
unborn child dead with lightning bolts
she stood in the rain
waving her fist
cursing god and when nothing happened
shirt went back into the house and said
you see if god exists he would surely
have taken up my challenge i've proved
irrefutably that god does not exist
madeleine attempted to rebuild her life
she graduated from ashland college in
1948 and from south texas school of law
in 1952.
in 1952 john may's sister-in-law invited
him to join her family's business
in baltimore maryland they bought a
small brick row house at 1526 winford
road in a quiet middle class
neighborhood and madeleine began her
diary in which she voiced some guarded
optimism for the future
on january 5th 1953 as her first entry
she wrote the year has the look and the
feel of a good one well paced eventful
prosperous
she nevertheless listed several issues
that gave her pause and even presented a
dismal foundation on which to build so
she wrote to begin with she found that
the maryland bar examiners did not
recognize her law degree because south
texas law school had not yet been
accredited so she couldn't take the bar
exam
second the family continued to be in
financial difficulties
madeleine reported that her former
employer had written a condemning note
to the pub to the public department of
public welfare for whom she wanted to
work and that she had been forced to
take a job at the glennell martin
company instead she hated the job
and as months passed even this level of
madeleine's optimism slowly waned and
her frustration grew the family's
financial situation improved only
slightly and she felt trapped by her job
and frustrated by her life she observed
in her diary i don't like these row
houses nests of bees identical homes
with identical people and identical
lives yet truly i long to be part of
society
i would like to have a routine humdrum
existence or so i thought
a set of contradictions if there ever
was one
madeleine had moments of renewed
optimism and satisfaction but generally
the remaining years of the decade as
reflected in her diary were marred by
even greater despair and anger both with
herself and the world around her
she condemned her own laziness and
mistakes but she also condemned the
society in which she lived
for the situation in which she found
herself at that point on may 16 1953 she
confided to her diary there's nothing
for me ahead but a petty existence eeked
out from day to day i'm frustrated and
bitter and full of hate
madeleine also commented on world and
national events again in an increasingly
critical manner she grew highly critical
of joseph mccarthy richard nixon in the
anti-communist movement she joined
americans for democratic action then the
socialist labor party and then the
socialist workers party
madeleine became an early proponent of
feminism and an opponent of french and
american involvement in vietnam she
opposed the korean war the testing of
nuclear weapons in the atmosphere and
suppression of the rights of algerians
and black south
africans and a proponent of improving
the lot of migrant workers
but madeline couldn't live by politics
alone on july 3 1953 she wrote in her
diary i need to unlock again my emotions
i need to love
i've been pent up and hard and cynical
too long
i need to be a woman
soon thereafter madeleine began seeing
michael fiorillo from new york city whom
she met at work she converted to her
diary that she felt like a high school
girl again he folded me into his arms
and naturally and completely kissed me
like i have wanted to be kissed for 20
years i was so absolutely pleased and
surprised
i almost got kidnish interesting image
from madeleine o'hare
on november 16 1954 madeleine gave birth
to her second out of wedlock child whom
she married john garth murray after the
father of her first son
fiorillo challenged his paternity
of john garth but lost
again i would remind you this is the
1950s
madeleine also ruminated about her
social situation i say i have bad luck
but don't we make our luck isn't it a
combination of poor judgment and
indiscretion
then there's a pause and a very key
transition i don't really believe that
why do i write it i see social remorse
that are wrong stupid and immoral the
people who live by the moors see me as a
flagrant violator an extremist something
foreign to them and dangerous
by the early months of 1955 madeleine
hit absolute bottom but she refused to
be counted out as there was no place to
go but up
she attacked the moral code inculcated
in school church and other institutions
she explained that she ignored the code
completely and lived by raw rules that
disgust revolt and injure
everyone is playing a horrible game of
lip service versus the darkest and most
cruel conduct in dead earnestness it's
macabre and hysterically funny these
dark games are dangerous and men die for
false ideals and distorted truths and
will forever and ever
amen
the question she continued was how to
resolve yourself to this insane
situation the answer she suggested to
reject it indeed to topple it
consequently i will be ostracized she
wrote by my own volition from society
henceforth and since i've decided i'm
rather happy about it
although she would waver in her
commitment from time to time madeline
was committed to a life of confrontation
with american society what she needed
was a cause
madeleine might have committed herself
to any number of causes her feminism
nuclear disarmament social reform
political activism
atheism was neither her only nor even
really at this point her primary concern
as the decade drew to a close madeline
contemplated
how she would sort of translate this
into an action against the world and she
began to think about first of all
leaving the country she thought about
renouncing her citizenship and even the
possibility of defecting to the soviet
union but she abandoned that idea and
resolved to focus her energy on
reforming the united states
that idea and she then decided she would
enroll at howard university a
traditionally black institution seeking
a master's degree in psychiatric work
but she was expelled after
quarreling with her advisor
madeline found a job in the social
security administration
but was fired
and during the spring and summer of 1959
for about three months she moved into an
apartment with a man called ricardo she
left her sons in the care of her parents
admitted that her family wasn't happy
with her decision she hoped all would be
reconciled in time but the relationship
failed and she moved back home again
this is when she took on the baltimore
public schools
when they moved to baltimore madeleine
enrolled william in park school a
private school
and then which then moved to west
baltimore and william had to commute to
the school after a semester of an
exhausting long commute and a struggle
to meet the tuition bills she decided to
switch him to the local public school
william later recalled that as they
passed through the halls of woodbourne
junior high his mother was perturbed to
see the student standing and pledging
allegiance to the flag and angry when
she observed them bowing their head and
reciting the lord's prayer
upon entering the counselor's office
madeleine confronted the man who greeted
her asking why the students were praying
it's un-american it's unconstitutional
she proclaimed and let him know that she
did not want her son to be taught any
prayers
the man was clearly flustered by
madeleine's charge and at first
responded by noting that nobody else had
ever complained and that even those who
were not very religious thought prayer
recitation set a nice tone for the day
after he regained his composure he added
there were prayers in the school of the
city before there was a united states of
america if our forefathers had wanted us
to stop this practice they would have
told us that when they formed this
government
his response infuriated madeleine he
probably should have stopped there
she informed the counselor that people
like him had to be stopped whereupon he
replied then why don't you sue us
he could not have anticipated what he
had suggested to be sure
on october 27 1960 the face of william
murray graced page one of the baltimore
morning sun beneath the headline
boy 14 box at bible reading the three
column article reported the facts of the
case the murray's position and that this
was the first reported challenge to the
baltimore school board's rule on prayer
since its adoption in 1905.
telephone calls began immediately first
from local reporters to national
reporters all seeking interviews on
november 2nd 1960 maryland attorney
general c ferdinand seibert ruled that
objections to exercise exercises were
not a valid reason for non-compliance
with the public school law and that
anyone who absented himself from school
to avoid them could be prosecuted for
truancy
cybert recommended that pupils who
objected to bible reading or school
prayer be allowed to remain silent upon
the written request of their parents or
be excused from the exercise he
acknowledged that such non-conformity
would cause individual embarrassment but
that was the price to be paid for
non-conformity
now there was a little bit for everybody
in this ruling uh the morning religious
exercises remain but the murrays won the
right to absent william from it
madeleine however viewed the decision as
almost total victory for the school
board and would not compromise she
pressed on the murray's attorney filed a
petition for a writ of mandamus on
december 8th 1960 in the superior court
of baltimore the case initially called
william j murray iii versus baltimore
school board became murray v curlett
curlett being the school board president
on april 27 1961 judge gilbert
pendergast
dismissed the murray's petition and the
murrays appealed the decision to the
maryland court of appeals and that court
ruled against the murrays as well and
finally the murrays appealed the court
to the united the case to the united
states supreme court or it was joined
with shemp the case i mentioned earlier
which came out of pennsylvania where the
state court actually ruled that the
state law was unconstitutional so it was
an interesting joining of cases
on june 17 1963 the u.s supreme court
returned the murray and shemp cases the
court declared unconstitutional the
maryland and pennsylvania laws requiring
bible reading and prayer recitation in
the public schools because they violated
the establishment clause of the first
amendment the majority opinion
maintained that the establishment clause
is violated by any government
sponsorship of religion in the public
schools regardless of whether a showing
of coercion exists
this is a reference to the letting yeah
william have the opportunity to leave
the room as justice tom
clark put it for a law to be valid there
must be a secular legislative purpose
and a primary effect that neither
advances nor inhibits religion and the
maryland and pennsylvania laws failed
that test
madeleine murray felt vindicated by the
decision and she best in the sunlight of
public and media attention she vowed to
go beyond removing prayer and bible
reading from the nation's public schools
but has it been the case throughout her
adult life she was not without her
personal second thoughts
she continually struggled to understand
herself and her seemingly uncontrollable
need to challenge and change some of the
most dearly held beliefs in the world
around her several years after the cases
were decided she described one such
contemplated contemplative moment
one evening in baltimore she as she sat
alone in her basement library trying to
decide whether to press ahead with the
lawsuit madame reflected on her sense of
separateness
when we first moved into those row
houses in baltimore she wrote i think i
had picked out one for purchase
deliberately in the hopes that i could
be like everyone else
i had wanted so desperately to fit in
but i could not engage in conversation
about which bleach was the whitest for
the wash
i never gave a damn about chlorophyll
and toothpaste the idiotic idea of back
fence visiting left me completely cold
she acknowledged that none of her work
had ever fully occupied her mind and
thinking processes and that out of
frustration she would too often pace the
basement library floor like a lioness
caged the wrap of loneliness of
aloneness always around me i just wanted
one person somewhere sometime to
understand me
it's been argued that the singular
importance of murray v curlett was the
involvement of madeleine murray who sees
the opportunity to attain national
notoriety as the leader of the american
atheist movement when the newspapers
reported on the murray champ decision
madeleine william and john garth were
pictured standing on the steps of the
u.s supreme court building the shems
were nowhere to be found soon every
newspaper magazine and radio and
television commentator in the land
referred to her as the woman who brought
the case that removed prayer and bible
reading from the schools and madeleine
resented any attempt to limit her
responsibility in those cases she laid
claim to being the primary figure in the
1963 supreme court decision by arguing
that edward chimp in his failure to
seize the moment and lead the movement
for separation of church and state
forfeited that role
forty years after she initiated the case
four years after her mysterious
disappearance the washington post made
the point that the murrays were neither
the only plaintiffs involved in the 63
supreme court ruling but they weren't
even essential
madeleine however it added was the
litigant with the loudest mouth and it
made her a celebrity
one of the earliest major published
exposes on madeline murray appeared in
life magazine in 1964. life used as its
title the most hated woman in america
making it household currency author jane
howard described madeleine as america's
most outspoken and militant atheist her
cause was the total and utter separation
of church and state and a land where
most people believe in god and those who
don't keep quiet howard wrote such a
cause is as good a way to win public
favor as bringing back polio
murray she added which outlawed official
prayer ceremonies in public schools and
made the name of murray and ethema to
millions of americans madeleine agreed
with howard's assessment and made note
of the death threats she had received
madeleine said that she loved life but
that she simply had to fight which she
knew in her guts was wrong she quipped i
think sooner or later some night some
nuts going to get a message from jesus
christ and i'm going to have had it but
as long as i'm still around i'm going to
keep on being a squeaking wheel
now i don't have time to go into her
life after murray in any great detail
but let me just comment on it briefly
because i think it's important
madeleine murray issued her challenge to
the baltimore public schools during the
cold war this helps explain the public
reaction to her protest against prayer
in the public schools and the outrage at
her success
indeed although it made her the most
hated woman in america it also made her
one of the best known and it gave her a
cause that would serve her well
during the quite different reform-minded
counter-cultural even iconoclastic late
1960s and 1970s it was during those
years that madeline marie o'hare as head
of american atheist in society for the
separation of church and state reached
her peak of popularity and influence
she and her organizations challenge the
words under god and the pledge of
allegiance
in god we trust on american currency the
tax-exempt status of religious
organizations
the use of chaplains in the military and
open sessions of government
the pope's performance of mass on the
washington mall
uss us astronauts reading the bible in
space
and much more the list goes on she lost
most of her cases but as she readily
admitted she never expected to win
at least in the short run what she
sought was to make cases for what she
saw as violations of constitutional
provisions for the separation of church
and state and the rights of atheists as
well as what she saw as the destructive
oppressive power of religion in america
in the most visible manner to educate
americans really on these matters for
the future
she believed that although a fervent
minority believed in and defended this
unofficial de facto establishment of
religion most did not or didn't care
not seeing the danger of it and
therefore could be persuaded to oppose
it and for a time during the 1960s and
70s o'hare was one of the most visible
reformers in america
she was on every major tv and radio talk
show her face was on the cover of every
leading magazine her actions were
covered regularly in the press the fbi
had a file on her when i wrote that i
realized that they had a file on
everybody so that wasn't any great
accomplishment uh death war death
threats against her were a common
occurrence and she often had to be
hustled away under guard when her public
remarks incited crowds to menacing
levels
but then the times changed again the
cold war reheated during the reagan
years complete with renewed ideological
crusades against the evil empire and
turning a cold shoulder to liberals
reformers and those standing outside the
new ideological mainstream
the more conservative mood of the nation
the fact that much of what people found
so shocking and appealing about o'hare
and her cause during the previous
decades became old hat and the errors
made on her own part all precipitated
o'hare's gradual decline o'hare roared
in opposition to the reagan decade but
she was tilting with windmills
especially when those to whom she once
appealed tired of the battle for liberal
reform it might well have been heard to
respond madeleine we've heard it before
as o'hare lived into her mid 60s and
once again faced issues she thought long
ago resolved she increasingly despaired
and spoke of ill health and being
exhausted she rallied at times in
challenging the new christian right and
allied forces mustered
to drag the nation back into the dark
ages as she saw it
but then her son william murray in whose
name she brought the case
defected was born again and became her
enemy
the press had a field day with the turn
of events and its coverage of american
atheist activities was limited to
periodic confrontations between the two
groups portrayed much like the carnival
will come to town complete with
sideshows and other attractions at which
to marvel or laugh but certainly not to
take seriously
as o'hare prepared to retire her
american atheist faced its most serious
challenge since its inception when
o'hare rose to prominence attracted
people she attracted people to her and
expanded her operation
she also became increasingly dictatorial
she had no patience with those of lesser
skills in energy or who challenged or
even questioned her and as a result she
alienated many of those who might have
served
her organization well
this was not a significant problem as
long as she had the limelight it became
a problem as she lost that prominence
and members of her own organization
began to blame her for the decline of
the movement and sought to remove her
from power
others simply sensed no doubt her
growing weakness and moved in for the
kill for their own reasons
trusting no one beyond her immediate
circle o'hare insisted on passing the
baton to her son
john garth murray his leadership and
interpersonal skills were questionable
and the method by which he was thrust
into power outraged many within the
national organization
combined with its mounting financial
problems on the uh on the eve of
madeleine john and robin murray's
disappearance in 1995 american atheists
seemed on the verge of being torn apart
if not collapsing altogether
but madeline murray o'hare's life ended
on a much more bizarre note
on august 28 1995 madeleine john and
robin murray
robin was madeline's granddaughter who
was actually william's daughter
estranged
disappeared
speculation arose that madeleine had
died and that john and robin had
secreted her body away for cremation and
burial out of the public eye as
madeleine had requested
some believe that the trio had fled the
country due to their financial problems
absconding with whatever organization
monies remained this interpretation
stuck by the way i just got off the net
there's a production opening in new york
at the wash and fold theater project
i'm from new york and that's a new one
on me and it's called the last days of
madeleine murray o'hare in exile and
what it has is madeline muriel here
absconding with the money living on a
south sea island and going through sort
of re rethinking her whole life so this
this interpretation appealed to a lot of
people
and of course a few thought they had
been murdered by some by some irate
chryster as she put it who madeline
predicted all along would kill her
indeed the trio had been murdered but
not by a chrysler
instead they were killed by an ex-con
in former employee whom madeleine once
charged with theft of organization funds
david waters entered a plea of guilty in
that case in exchange for probation and
was ordered to make restitution
he also vowed revenge a vow he kept
waters and two accomplices abducted the
trio forced them to withdraw over five
hundred thousand dollars from the
organization's bank accounts killed them
dismembered their bodies and buried them
in shallow graves outside san antonio
texas
in january 2001 waters once again in a
plea bargain led authorities to those
graves where the remains were recovered
william murray claimed and buried them
without prayer in an undisclosed
location in the hills near austin
well let me conclude by just talking a
little bit about madeleine's legacy
she's gone but certainly not forgotten
or at least her legacy continues to
challenge us to this day
many americans still refusing to accept
the supreme court's ruling and murray
continue to seek creative and
constitutionally acceptable ways around
that decision
and other challenges that madeleine
brought but failed to win continue to be
brought up the most recent being the
case brought by michael newdow on behalf
of his eight-year-old daughter to the
ninth u.s circuit court of appeals in
san francisco which resulted in a ruling
that the words under god were
unconstitutional when uttered by
teachers leading school children in
their morning exercises
in the midst of dying telecoms charges
of corruption lodged against major
corporations an exploding deficit a
middle east in flames the decision still
set off such an uproar that the judge in
the case alfred goodwin felt obliged to
block his own ruling until a higher
court had a chance to hear the case i
really think madeleine would have been
much amused if she'd been around at that
point
thank you
be happy to take some questions or these
try to answer them
ballpark how many legal cases did she
bring
uh and did she ever represent herself or
did she always even with her law
background or did she always get legal
counsel she brought hundreds
of cases and was responsible for
hundreds more because her organization
also had stake state and local chapters
and she would work with them to bring
cases at one point it's funny in the
early part of her career she was
convinced that the supreme court was the
only way to go because they were the
only ones with courage came out of the
murray decision then later on she kind
of decided well that's not where we want
to go because she thought the tone of
the court was changing so she changed
her focus to start all her cases at the
local level saying we can change things
here and she was very dramatic about
going into she lived in austin texas so
she would go into the austin city
council chambers and demand that they
not pray before you know the session
that this was her feeling that
grassroots kind of behavior was the way
uh to go
so she did bring all of these cases now
she never took the bar exam
and shows she could never practice law
she could never sign or represent
herself in in that sense
she always had attorneys who worked for
her to do it but by all
measures all references
sometimes angrily by her attorneys she
insisted on writing many of the briefs
herself
she just she would write them and have
them sign it if they tried to change
anything she just sort of tear it out of
their hands and say you're done and that
was the end of it so she did write many
of them or something and they are really
written very i i would recommend many of
the statements the priests that were
entered in the murray case i think are
the best representation of atheism in
america that you're going to get they're
really very good
so
before i came tonight i was talking with
somebody about your book and they said
madeline murray o'hare gave atheists a
bad name
did she catch much heat from within the
movement
to tone it down and try to become more
you know
and pop atheism right that's a good
question it kind of relates back to
maura's question earlier um and when she
talked about her being as one of many
liberals of the time
her behavior was such that
other liberals if we can call her a
liberal and almost you know so many
people in her movement rejected her
because she was just so
studiedly crude
and vulgar
that people just wouldn't have anything
to do with her at first they were okay
through much of the 60s because that was
kind of a crazy time anyway and
everyone was acting bad uh you know it
was easy in a sense for madeleine she
had lots of cover for her behavior
as you go into the late 70s and in the
80s in a more
civil time if you want you could take
that as a positive or negative view all
the time um
people really began to just reject her
and whenever she was rejected she tended
to be even more outrageous in her
behavior
one typical scene and it comes you know
she had a great way of mimicking so
people wouldn't miss the point she went
into a bingo
game in a church and did the christ
thing from the new testament went in and
tipped over the tables and started
screaming at the top of her lungs in
order to make the point this was sort of
typical and they did distant that many
people did distance herself from
themselves from her so
many times the americans who are
perceived in their own country are
admired and revered abroad for example
woody allen in france marilyn monroe
jerry lewis
roman polanski well he was a european
though how do you have any information
about how she was accepted abroad
uh chastised here an outsider but was
she respected elsewhere
she actually started the international
atheist association she started herself
and she was she was fairly well regarded
abroad
she tended to behave a little better
when she went abroad and i think that
helped too and also
people were less
obsessed
with atheists in the movement abroad so
she could go as she did
to sweden denmark india
france many places and meet with
atheists and no one really cared
you know what they didn't you didn't
bring about the reaction that it did in
the united states so she didn't have
that kind of visibility but she seems to
have been fairly highly regarded enough
to be elected the president of that
group for several years so she did
pretty well abroad
i have a question to go back to the
diaries
i'm always interested in documentation
of scholarship and so on how did you
gain access to the diaries
and did you have access to
documents that american atheists keep or
or even documents of her enemies and so
forth
um let me answer the first question
about the diaries the diaries were when
they were found were actually sold
at an auction to help pay off the
organization's debts they were purchased
by an attorney
from austin
and it took me about a year to persuade
him
for reasons which i'm still not quite
sure to let me use to read
the diaries and i'm very grateful
i did not intend to include much of
madeleine's personal life
in this book i really wanted to look at
atheism in cold war america as an issue
with madeleine as a representation of
that issue
most of the stuff that had been written
about madeleine was pretty
antagonistic
um and what i found
from my research most of it was wrong
and that's why i had to in a sense
retreat and i was also
constantly challenged by this idea of
why did she do it and i really took the
diaries to help me figure that out um
also purchased as part of the diaries
were many boxes of personal documents
from her life
which was another one birth certificates
that's another story read the chapter in
the book on birth certificates because
she not she would have one birth
certificate for her son william
which was probably the original one then
she went and had a second one done with
different names
and she did the same thing when her
second son
was born and she was constantly
playing if you will these kinds of games
but the documentation is really there's
quite a bit now as far as american
atheists are concerned
i was not very successful
they were very protective
of her i think i would have had better
luck if she hadn't disappeared when i
was writing the book
and then they were under such siege
thinking that she'd absconded with the
money that they sort of drew up the
drawbridge and decided they weren't
going to let anyone
near that documentation however having
said that i it worked out okay because
really there isn't much personal
material an american atheist there's a
lot of literature it's a wonderful
collection on atheism
madeleine collected it but there wasn't
a lot of personal papers one thing about
madeleine madeleine wrote everything
down and got it published she had
newsletters she had magazines she had a
radio show and then published
transcripts in the radio shows so there
wasn't much that madeleine thought or
said it didn't make it into print so
yes if i can follow on that question
uh was madeleine
spiritual at all did she believe in
spirituality
and in examining her diaries
do you
perceive it all over time any kind of
spiritual or even emotional growth going
on
oh
interesting ending to that question um
i didn't detect very much of anything in
terms of a spiritual understanding
there's just nothing there
to deal with she was a committed as she
believed rationalist who just didn't
believe in any kind of spiritual
focus or force in the world
i didn't see
very much there at all
um
and i think if anything
rather than looking at it in terms of
spiritual growth i think if anything
whatever
spiritual
feeling she might have had
um
were lost
over time she died or you know her last
few she was a very very bitter angry
woman at the end
okay
you mentioned in europe that she could
become well behaved
i wonder
was there anything endearing or soft
about this woman or was it a show
i mean
understanding a little bit about the
atheist leaders now in the organizations
it's a plethora of people being shunned
and splitting off and so it seems more
normal right to me so i was just
wondering is it is this harshness just
part of a show or
i think to a large extent it was
it was it was her performance so that
she would be noticed
but she was a pretty
outspoken woman and even those who liked
her
said that in private she was pretty
tough to be around
she didn't tolerate fools
well at all and if you said something
she didn't agree with she let you know
there was no question on the other hand
they say she had a fabulous sense of
humor
and
you know could be
fun to be around but those people were
pretty few and far between i think the
frustration came out you know with her
over the years now
you mentioned europe i think one of the
reasons again i i want to emphasize that
i believe that she was
better behaved in europe is because she
didn't have the spotlight to misbehave
they didn't care that she was there so
there's another atheist group it just
wasn't a big issue
in europe one of the things that kind of
ignited her in the united states was
that she wherever she went the spotlight
was on her and
she would seize it by behaving the way
she did um i suppose she could have
engaged in some outrageous behavior
abroad but she just didn't it wasn't
there
in your
reading of her diaries and in your
discussion of that early period of her
life and her own comment about
i believe it was in one in a later
period of her life where she wondered
to herself why she always wanted to be
angry and and against something
it sounded as though you might be
implying that she was or portraying her
as
a rebel with the cause
by nature that that was her sort of
fundamental personality bent and
further that that perhaps more than
anything more than particular rational
beliefs might be what was driving her
and i just wonder if you would
comment further on that if that is what
you're implying in the book and if she
ever herself seemed to if that is the
case
did she ever herself seem to come to
some kind of an underst self
understanding
about
what was um
making her tick in terms of why she
needed to be
always against something to thrive
yeah clearly there was a rebellious
nature there and she knew it
i think to a certain extent
anyone in that situation must have had
moments of loneliness when she wished
she wasn't the way that she was because
she led i mean it was a pretty desperate
life
i didn't go into it but the two or three
years after the murray case
um she had to have guards
her house was stoned windows broken
tires slashed her sons were beat up
william was thrown before a bus i mean
it was pretty tough going and i'm sure
that she had moments
when she wished things were different
um
but i think she she was either worked
into put herself into a situation where
she had nothing else that she could do
but fight back
and one could put a gendered
interpretation of what's going on but i
really do see this as a woman
in the early 50s
very bright
very well educated who made some
mistakes and never got over it and
decided rather than apologizing for it
she was going to pull the system down
around her
i really think that was a lot of the
motivation
okay well thank you very much i
appreciate it
[Music]
brian lebeau is author of the atheist
madeline murray o'hare it's published by
new york university press on the web at
nyupress.org
next week on public lives a new
biography of andrew jackson from andrew
burstein